it's a standoff between the world's most
prestigious tennis tournament and the
sport's global governing bodies both the
atp and wta tours have stripped
wimbledon of ranking points meaning
players won't be able to earn any here
this year because the tournament banned
players from russia and belarus woodward
and says it had no option but to exclude
them under uk government guidance
following russia's invasion of ukraine
in a statement put out by the club on
friday it called the decision not to
award points disproportionate in the
context of the exceptional and extreme
circumstances going on to say that it
was damaging to all players who compete
on the tour
the atp and wta have allowed players
from russia and belarus to compete as
neutrals including at the paris open
starting on sunday
the atp has put out a statement
explaining why it was effectively
turning wimbledon into an exhibition
tournament
it says the ability for players of any
nationality to enter tournaments based
on merit and without discrimination is
fundamental to our tour
wimbledon's ban ruled out top players
including men's world number two daniel
medvedev from russia and last year's
women's semi-finalist irina sabalenko
from belarus
serbia's novak djokovic is one of
several players to have criticized the
ban now he's set to lose his world
number one status as he can't get the
2000 points he earned by winning here
last year but experts don't predict a
boycott it's really an interesting sort
of play of power and we'll see sort of
who has the strength and the leverage
here but i think wimbledon feels as
though they are the most prestigious
event you'll notice that no players are
boycotting it's not until the players
who they might be angry but they're not
angry enough to stay home the all
england lawn tennis club says it's
considering its options and is in
discussions with its grand slam
colleagues but the reverberations from
its decision are likely to be felt for
some time to come nadim baba al jazeera
london